[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
oh
tous
on
les derniers rayons du soleil accompagne
une jeune artiste réunionnaise hamas car
un jardin botanique du département de la
réunion
je m'appelle gia pas j'ai 38 ans je suis
originaire et enfants et je suis
aquarelliste botanique depuis environ
huit ans les yeux grands ouverts sur les
détails de notre environnement
cet artiste dessine une réalité qu'on
oublie d'apprécier ce qui me plaît c'est
la fleur déjà c'est la structure qui est
très élégante jupe et la design vraiment
moderne c'est la dynamique de la plante
c'est pas juste essayé de copier parce
que c'est vrai que il faut essayer de se
rapprocher de ce convoi mais c'est pas
comme ça il ya aussi tout un travail de
recherche de vos positions de création
une peinture feu demandé entre des
dizaines d'heures à avoir plus de 100
heures donc c'est vraiment ce qui
demande beaucoup de temps le lien avec
ce patrimoine départemental est donc
tout trouvé un cadre d'exception idéal
ouvert à tous les arts un jardin
botanique historiquement ont toujours eu
cette vocation d'illustrations qui est
en dehors de l'aspect connaissances
botaniques qui est aussi un moyen de de
vulgariser
la flore de montrer des détails que
souvent on ne voit pas et l'art est
vraiment un vecteur important de
connaissances
[Musique]
je suis très très contente d'exposer un
mascara parce que vivant en afrique du
sud j'ai déjà exposé
au jardin botanique de kirstenbosch au
cas j'ai déjà exposé à johannesburg à
pretoria durban mais jamais à l'heure
et ça d'autant plus d'importance pour
moi et de valeurs d'exposer ici
difficile devant autant de détails de
rester indifférents les couleurs les
formes illuminent les visages
le souci de précision quand même quand
on voit tous les petits détails de
couleurs etc
donc on connaît un petit peu la peinture
on sait que c'est pas évident d'arriver
à
à ceux rendus là faut déjà chez les maka
tu es un artiste je viens de les
découvrir ce qu'elles étaient habitués
ici c'est pour ça et on voit bien la
précision dans les traits tous les
bienfaits et quand on prend un peu le
temps et qu'on est qu'on les observe
on se rend compte que vraiment il ya des
détails qui sont magnifiques et qui est
vraiment méritent qu'on les regarde avec
attention
une exposition à suivre tout le mois de
juillet un mois de vacances où vous
trouverez également dans ce jardin bien
d'autres activités
[Musique]